تم إعداد لقاء اثنين من الصديقين ليكونا
قادة من أجل الحياة يستعرضون
رؤيتهم لنظام عالمي ما بعد أمريكا
في ظرف من الظروف ، وهو تعزيز مصداقية
للزعيم الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يُظهر أن لديه
صديقًا قويًا في الزعيم الصيني شي جين بينغ.
أصدرت المحكمة الجنائية الدولية
مذكرة توقيف بحقه لارتكابه
جرائم حرب وزعم بشحن
أطفال أوكرانيين إلى روسيا ، وحتى مع
عزل الغرب له وسط
غزوه المتوقف لأوكرانيا ، كتبت هي وبوتين
مقالات رأي متوهجة حول
علاقات بلدهما وصفتها بعلاقتهما.
صداقة أبدية ،
يقول بوتين إن الاثنين يقفان جنبًا إلى
جنب ضد
جهود أمريكا العدوانية المتزايدة لردع روسيا والصين ،
ويحاول شي جين بينغ السير في
خط دقيق حتى الآن دون تقديم
مساعدات مميتة لروسيا على الرغم من أن الولايات المتحدة تقول
إنه ربما يفكر في ذلك.  بينما
ترفض أيضًا إدانة الغزو ،
في الوقت نفسه ، تستفيد بكين أيضًا
من عزلة التجارة الروسية
بين الدولتين قفزت إلى 190
مليار دولار العام الماضي بزيادة قدرها
30 في المائة عن عام 2021 مما قلل من
تأثير العقوبات التي تقودها الولايات المتحدة مع
اقتناص الشركات الصينية للطاقة الرخيصة من
روسيا تمنح الكرملين أموالاً رئيسية
لتمويل الغزو لكن بكين تريد من
العالم أن يركز بدرجة أقل على
صداقتهما وأكثر على دور شي كرجل
دولة عالمي يمكنه التوسط في
صفقات سلام مثل الصفقة التاريخية التي ساعد في
صوغها لإعادة العلاقات بين المملكة العربية السعودية
وإيران.  لقد تحدثت إلى
الناس في هذا الزقاق السكني القديم في بكين
للتعرف على ما
يعتقده الصينيون بشأن زيارة XI jinping ،
أخبرني هذا الرجل أنها زيارة
جيدة لأنها يمكن أن تحسن
العلاقات بين الصين وروسيا ، كما
يقول إنه يحب بوتين.  كثيرًا لأنه
رجل قوي ورائع في حرب أوكرانيا ،
يقول إنه يأمل فقط أن يتمكن الجميع من إقامة
علاقة سلمية
تخبرني هذه المرأة أنها تأمل أن
تفوز روسيا بالحرب لكن السلام أفضل
امرأة أخرى تقول إن الحرب وفقدان
الأرواح أمر مؤلم ومفجع.
لمشاهدتها تقول إنه من الخطأ أن ترسل أمريكا
أسلحة إلى أوكرانيا وهي تؤمن
برؤية XI jinping للسلام العالمي
عندما سألتها عن رأيها في بوتين ،
أجابت أنه بارع وحاسم
وسريع وصعب ولكن عندما أتابع
وأسأل عما إذا كانت  سمعت عن إصدار المحكمة الجنائية الدولية
مذكرة توقيف بحق بوتين ، فأجابت أنني
لم أكن أعرف أنه بدأ الحرب بعد كل شيء
يجب أن يجلس مع زيلينسكي
ويتحدث عن
مصلح الأحذية هذا ويقول لماذا
يقاتلون ، فهذا لا يفيد أي شخص ولكننا
لا نفعل ذلك.  لا أعرف من بدأ الحرب ،
ويضيف أن الأوكرانيين على حق ،
فهي لا تحتاج إلى إقناع
الجمهور في الصين حيث تخضع وسائل الإعلام
للرقابة الشديدة على مزايا علاقته الوثيقة
مع بوتين ، لكن بقية العالم
يراقب لمعرفة ما سيحدث.
ادعاءات بكين بالحياد سيلينا وانغ سي إن إن
بكين